ouai c'est trop bien je me battais pas
comme aujourd'hui donc j'allais de plus
quand vous battez que c'est quand vous
passez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui faut pas
me faire chier ah oui c'est à dire
j'espérais chose dont je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose ça si vous
battez c'est qu'un problème parce qu'un
allemand dans le regard on voit déjà que
c'est pas la peine d'aller si je m'étais
moi coup de pression moi cela m'est
arrivé aux affaires mais voilà dans mon
vingtième simulation bien que dans la
rue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on avait la rue oui oui et on faisait
les mettre un coup de circuit
d'accord vous avez mettre à contribution
ses mots assez vous annoncer les noms je
découpe est alors allé aussi alors on
est à et attention vous savez ma
taxation nous est hostile
on marche dans la rue parti bah du coup
oh [ __ ] pas mais ça [ __ ] oui ah
c'est toi qui ne rallume était chiante
bénard
[Applaudissements]
dans le regard celui-là mais regarde non
ya pas de regards sont faits rien
souvent le chouf précieux jure que c'est
vrai j'ai déjà vu des gens alors que
changer de trottoir
mais quoi oui beaucoup leur est
nécessaire à cause du regard des regards
non mais c'est peut-être l'odeur et la
raison
[Applaudissements]
le lui qui se bat c'est parce qu'on dit
tiens j'ai une chance d'assister aux
débats pas là alors votre facture alors
on est dedans on est dans le micro tu me
regardent comme ça quoi tu me regardent
comme ça es tu as perdu ta langue
hélas la troisième tracé baisse les yeux
goethe a dit baisse les yeux quel jeu
maintenant qu'elle est une fille tu
[Applaudissements]
parles à ta mère m'avait pas là donc
s'attendre je parle ce qui t'arrive
l'espèce de troisième avertissement même
année qu'est ce qui va se passer au
quatrième avertissement vraiment savoir
moi ta main à la pâte à reconnaître et
faire une bonne émission
l'espoir des cendres à l'histoire éric
martin ouais donc eric mais les cinémas
de la tension tht alicia deux autres
dans le passé abena pour la pour
l'histoire parce que quoi elle se dit
qu'on passe amène en même temps leur
sera remis en jeu on va pas ça bizarre
ça menace tout son saoul
t'as vu comment je suis am i show tu as
vu ce qui se serait passé va c'est ce
qui s'est passé ouais franchement
ouais bah je pense qu'ils auraient mis
des best-of pendant un mois mon show ah
ouais j'aurais mis des best of on a
remarqué que j'aurais été en prison
parce que je t'aurais mieux en ce sens
cette venir reconnaît benjamin gille 2 3
fois de mauvais dos bof pas ouais quoi
c'est vraiment gentil mais c'est un
mythomane mythomane il fait il est même
pas peur à ma soeur
[Applaudissements]